The circle has a radius of 4
and its center is at the point 2, -3.
Great work if you found these two answers.
Again, we'll start by moving this constant term of -3 to the right hand side.
So we'll add 3 to both sides of our equation.
Then I'll regroup my two x terms together
on the left hand side,
and I'll regroup my two y terms on the
left hand side as well.
Now I'm ready to complete the square for the x terms
and the y terms.
We add 4 to complete the square for the x terms
and we addd 9 to complete the square for the y terms.
Keep in mind we also need to add 4 and 9
to the right hand side of our equation
to make sure it's balanced.
So, these three terms can be written as x - 2 squared
these three terms can be written as y + 3 squared
and then we simply combine these three terms to get +16.
So now our equation is in a form we recognise.
Our centre is at 2,-3.
Since the h value is +2
and the k value is -3.
We take the square root of our constant term
to get a radius equal to 4.
Again great solving if you got these two answers.